in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jesse
and Amanda are with us hey guys how are
ya we are great
welcome welcome where you all from
Indianapolis Motor suburbs not too bad a
drive down to Nashville but still a
pretty good haul no well thanks for
hanging out with us so you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes we are
I love it how much have you paid off
seventy nine thousand six 2304 I believe
pretty close all right
and how long did that take about 17
months way to go dude very well done and
your range of income during that time I
was about 135 140 okay and what did you
sell nothing we had a little bit of
money saved back but we call our
lifestyle a lot a bunch okay how much
minds you upside back about 22 okay that
makes me it makes my mouth a little bit
better but still you lived on nothing I
mean you've been on beans and rice rice
and beans we were close very cool what
kind of debt was the 80,000 I had to
serve an eviction notice to Sally it was
all Sallie Mae yeah
every bit of it yeah that was after 10
years of paying on it Wow and what's the
degrees in as my JD it was you okay him
okay all right so you're you're a lawyer
yes okay very cool and how long have you
all been married just over five years
okay so you're married into this mess I
did I came in debt-free and had a little
bit of cash yeah married a not so rich
lawyer okay but now he's a lot richer so
very well done very well done so what
happened 17 months ago do you know what
happened is we got on the same team
fighting for the same goal we have had a
budget and we had had cash for since we
got married but we weren't on the same
plan fighting for the same thing and my
husband listened to you three hours a
day
after a move for because he lost his job
we had to move and he started listening
to you three hours of the day and you
speak his love language and that is just
saying it how it is
oh and he had a change of heart and he
said one day as we were driving to
softball hey I think that we should do
this Financial Peace University and I
had been praying about this and so
inside of me I am jumping for joy and on
the outside I'm like oh I guess that
might be okay we're gonna go yeah you
sure you sure this is a good I love it
so you want to FAU to church we did and
I was actually at a church that we
weren't a member of but we looked at one
that provided free childcare because I
wasn't going to pay money for a
babysitter to learn about how to not
spend more money make sense and during
that time we were expecting our second
child and you would talk about how you
know you should kind of squirrel your
money away and so mom and baby are home
safe from the hospital and I thought to
myself oh that's someone else that's not
us oh and then at 32 weeks I'm sleeping
in my bed and my water breaks and so we
had an emergency c-section and NICU
experienced and then two and a half
months later a second hospitalization
after our insurance reset of course yes
of course that's the way that always
worries yeah yeah so really it was the
seventy nine thousand plus to max out of
pockets mm-hmm which were what ten grand
a pop about seven seven grand a block
and then another fourteen the right why
would that reset straddling in the deal
oh man we were prepared you never
prepared because we were had taken the
class by that point we're sacking away
the cash and oh you did sack it away
yeah I think you said you didn't think
it was you but you did it anyway
yes oh I thought you met you didn't do
it because it wasn't oh okay so you were
ready oh wow but it just it just slowed
down there that snowball okay good
that's awesomeness yeah well very cool
very cool well congratulations
mm-hmm how does it feel
see now at this stage of the game you've
fought so hard for a year and a half now
and the changes that you guys have gone
through in a year and a half how does
that feel it's very frame I mean it's
you know financial peace and freedom of
you that you preach and that's just what
it is you know and we look forward to
the next steps of it but it was it was a
long haul but really the financial part
was just a smaller piece of you know
kind of God's bigger plan and what he
was doing in our lives our marriage it
was just a you know both getting married
a little later we had our ways of doing
things that were perfectly fine you are
single but you know the the collision
course of strong wills this was really
the kind of the the thing that that put
us on the same page like like a man said
fighting for the same thing and and that
was an even bigger deal you know then
didn't even just the paying off of the
debt you know I never phrased it that
way but that's a you know it pops into
my head you're either gonna fight or you
say you might as well be fighting about
the same thing because you're gonna
fight so you need to be fighting
together or you're gonna be fighting
each other it's really what it comes
down to and most couples fight with each
other and like you said get married
little bit later you both already had
your ways of doing things it's harder
right it's harder to combine your value
systems and really just submit your will
to each other right to to go okay all
right we're gonna do this together and
this is the order and so on you know I
remember a stupid one of those it was
silly but Sharon was driving this you
guys are too young to remember but
you've probably seen pictures of them
those old light blue two-tone Astro van
we now remember those yeah we had one of
those and we were just coming in out of
going broke it's starting to make a
little money starting to dig out that we
dug out of the debt now we're starting
to have a little bit of money I got a
big check coming in and she's like this
car had man it had so many it was a
third transmission second engine it was
a it was a beater from hell I mean it
was so bad and she's dragging these poor
kids around in this whole thing and
she's like okay we're moving up in car
I'm like no I got a thing down to office
we got to do this investment now at the
office we had this unbelievable fight
because we were already went on with
money but it was like it was the only
fight was which
it wasn't we're gonna do both it was
which one was gonna come first right
well I
I've acquiesced we bought the car first
which was the right thing to do by the
way she was right but I've just always
business minded I'm one boom on got the
offices got something Lambo needs
something to go down over here you know
and but I remember that very distinctly
because we sat down we said okay we're
really not saying no all we're saying is
which ones first right right and that
was like this clarity this epiphany
moment we had and it was that same thing
and it's fighting with each other or
fighting together right for something it
was that exact same thing that's what
maybe that's what reminded me of it well
well done you two thank you you're
heroes man took control of your life but
most of all you did together
Amanda how does it feel now that you
know you were this is this was your like
your heart's desire and then he turns to
you going to softball practice and goes
hey I want to be on the same page do you
know it feels amazing I am just so
thankful that Ava debt is gone and now I
don't feel like we're financing small
things you know go into a movie isn't
something we're finding anything but
more than anything I'm just so thankful
for what it did for my faith and for my
marriage we move and the legacy that we
are passing on to our kids absolutely
absolutely and their names are they
Isabel and Isaiah okay all right I don't
know if Isaiah is gonna make it yeah oh
yes good here he goes back into the
picture all right good very cool in
there how old is he is 3 she was 3 in
June and Isaiah is right at 18 months
and I was a as the guy that spent little
time and NICU then he it looks like he's
doing pretty good though yeah pretty
healthy young man he's bounced back I
love it
no long-term issues right that's
awesomeness very cool all right Jesse
Amanda Isabel when Isaiah $80,000 paid
off in 17 months making 135 to 140 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
way to go you guys hey we got a copy of
Chris Logan's book retire inspired a
signed copy for you because that's the
next phase of your plan so that'll take
you on to the second part of your story
this chapter is closed you are debt free
baby man that's awesome
you know what life is gonna happen NICU
sometimes you get to spend all time
there life is gonna happen the
transmission is going to go out you lose
a job life's gonna happen
question is are you gonna be ready walk
around acting like it's not gonna happen
it's just kind of stupid innit it's time
for you to get ready now this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
the car
you